what's the best way to find the HCF and
LCM of three numbers let's say we have
to find the HCF an LCM of 70 80 and 120
we have to use a technique which gives
us both together the LCM as well as the
HCF the best way to do that would be to
reduce 70 80 and 120 to its prime
factors 70 equals 2 times 5 times 7 80
is 16 times 5 which can be written as 2
raised to 4 times 5 and 120 is 15 times
8 which in prime factored form can be
written as 2 cubed times 3 times 5 what
do we do now to keep it simple we can
quickly make columns of the list of
prime factors we have 2 3 5 & 7 in 70 we
have to raise to 1 5 raise to 1 and 7
raise to 1 in 80 we have to raise 2 4
and 5 raise to 1 and in 120 we have 2
cubed 3 raise to 1 and 5 raise to 1 with
this ready we can easily find the HCF
and the LCM HCF is the product of the
least powers of shared factors as there
are only two prime factors which are
shared we look at only those two columns
the least power in this column is 1 so
we write a 2 raised to 1 and in this
column as well the least power is 1 so
we multiply this with 5 raised to 1 and
the product equals 10 the HCF of these
three numbers is 10 for the LCM we take
the highest power of each factor the
factors need not be shared the highest
power in this column is 4 we write a 2
raised to
for here in this column we have 3 raise
to 1 why is this the highest because
others are 3 raise to 0 third column
it's 5 raise to 1 and the fourth column
has 7 raise to 1 as the highest power
this product equals 1680 that's the LCM
of 70 80 and 120 so we can see that with
a simple column structure we can easily
find the HCF and LCM of 3 numbers